were taught that stalin is just an
appalling monster this is utter nonsense
the economy grew massively under stalin
quicker than any society ever
industrialized and people's lives got a
whole lot better millions of people
capitalism generates poverty because it
concentrates wealth in a few hands
what's more important living out my
purpose and ambitions or living a safe
and guaranteed life should you not be
allowed to live out your purpose of
course you should but should somebody
starve so that you can do that i would
say capitalism kills 14 million people
each and every year
i don't think that's how the world works
do you i do yes i do
[Music]
my guest today is dr assatar baer who's
an associate professor at economics
of economics at riverside city college
he's a self-identified communist dr bear
frequently praises dictators like stalin
and mao dr pair speaks and writes about
meditation has written over 150 blog
posts
about heart-centered spiritual
development he has practiced meditation
since he was a small child
and he holds a phd in economics from the
university of massachusetts amherst doc
appreciate you for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you so much for having me on the
show i got to tell you i was on twitter
i was looking at twitter
moments after i post
a very positive capitalistic tweet
then i see your tweet come on i gotta
read it to everybody because this this
kind of uh
lets the audience know
you know how similar a belief system you
and i have and they're gonna be able to
enjoy it at the end of the day here we
go
your tweet that just came out let me see
this here
speaking of debates
i'm being interviewed by patrick bae
david and a few should be interesting ha
ha hashtag communism will win
i like your spirit of competition which
is a capitalistic quality i admire that
a lot anyways okay
so doc we got some time together if you
don't mind would you mind taking a
moment and kind of uh
uh sharing with the audience your
background upbringing
you know schooling how you came about
your philosophy so the audience can get
a better understanding of your
background sure um you know i grew up in
a spiritual community my
parents uh very interested in in
meditation philosophy and became uh
students of sufism uh and this is
western sufism sufism is the esoteric
tradition within islam so it's it's sort
of like kabbalah for for judaism or
or maybe gnosticism for for christianity
you know most religions have a kind of
esoteric side right so and sufism you
know is often very deeply embedded in
islamic culture uh but in the united
states it takes a very different kind of
form
and the order that that my family
belongs to is a very universalist
uh kind of
branch uh associated with a fellow named
hazuna nayakan
who taught sufism in the west
so you know that i grew up in a very
kind of alternative background
but it wasn't very political you know
there are there are uh political hippies
and non-political hippies you know and
this this is a non-political kind of
strain um but i got into uh radical
politics uh as a young person when i was
when i was a teenager
and it's at that point that i began to
to study marxism and i ended up uh
studying that quite seriously and i
studied in college and graduate school
with uh the noted marxist economist
richard wolff
uh and his longtime collaborator stephen
resnick who has now passed away sadly
so that's kind of my my training and
then
i had the idea that i would really like
to teach at a community college
uh because you know i i want to be able
to speak to working class people and
you know it seemed like that was the
best way to do it
now there's a lot of challenges that
come along with that um but and that's
what i've done for
about the last 20 years i did take five
years out of that uh and uh ran a
non-profit for so i haven't always been
an academic academic i left and then i
returned
and that's that's kind of my story
currently like you mentioned teach at
riverside city college in southern
california very cool i appreciate that
by the way if you don't mind going back
you said in high school you took
interest in politics
and you were always you know upping in
you know and what you guys were studying
philosophy all that stuff but why
why why marxism why karl marx was there
a teacher did somebody inspire you did
you watch a movie did you read a book
where did that inspiration come from
yeah it's a little hard to say at this
point i don't think there was a single
kind of source you know i i was in
exploration kind of mode um definitely a
book that interested me early on
was was by e.f schumacher and it's
called smallest beautiful this is not a
part of the marxist or communist can and
this is written by
a
sort of mainstream or maybe kind of
lefty
economist but it it i found it to be
very kind of um
freeing in terms of its outlook um and
that and that was one of the one of the
works that kind of set me on the path of
discovery i had a lot of dissatisfaction
uh with a kind of mainstream economics
which seemed to me
just very abstract and and very hard to
use and
and uh that it didn't it didn't seem to
connect with the kind of real problems
that seemed to be happening all around
us you know it was it was very very
stylized and and and so i i didn't
understand like why was that the case um
and but then when i would read other
things i was like oh okay well these
here they're talking about real stuff
um
so that was sort of the beginning for me
so so if i'm doing the math right 14
years old
uh
so you're saying
1987-ish 86-ish
who's president at the time i think
reagan is president at the time
milton friedman is probably all over the
place thomas soul is probably all over
the place so is it fair to say like it
was
maybe
friedman is on phil donahue and they're
debating nader ralph nader and some of
that stuff just didn't sit well with you
would you say friedman was one of the
guys that you didn't agree with
well yeah i mean friedman is somebody i
studied later and somebody who certainly
casts a long shadow in the field uh in
the culture as a whole
um
uh definitely you know an important
intellectual figure in terms of you know
what we could call the rise of
neoliberalism
or the
the neo-classical counter-revolution
that occurs because you know what
happens of course in the post-war era is
that keynesian economics becomes really
the dominant form of economic theory and
its focus is how can the state manage
and regulate capitalism right to
to the benefit of society that's the
kind of focus of keynesian theory and
friedman in the chicago school
really systematically attacked keynes in
theory uh in favor of you know a a
stripped down kind of free market and
that's that's the neoliberal kind of
philosophy right that the state should
have a very minimal
role uh in the economy
and and they were i think broadly
speaking successful at you know kind of
moving the pendulum back
towards a much more free market or
classical liberal or neo-liberal kind of
position got it and by the way just how
to cure if you and i were in 10th grade
together who who were you in 10th grade
was i in 10th grade
um
you know i had in high school i was it
sort of an introvert
um
i i did some sports but they were the
sort of nerdy sports you know i i
i rode crew and i ran track and you know
like the sports that nobody cares about
uh
i didn't much like uh you know i i like
i always liked athletics but i didn't
like the world of athletics all that
much you know why is that um
it seemed like it was filled with
bullies and douche bags you know
and uh i i love competition i love
athletic performance um
you know i i do martial arts uh it's one
of my hobbies i do judo and jiu jitsu
and boxing you know i i enjoy
competition but i don't enjoy
uh the putting down of the week you know
um i think competition should bring out
your best not be about
you know putting down somebody else and
and so it but i often saw that you know
in a kind of world of sports and i it
turned me off yeah i don't think that
can be debated i think uh uh there is a
a a big part of that in sports
and uh i can see that turning uh
some people off because there's the
smack talking the comparison you know
sometimes maybe you can't compete with
somebody else because they have certain
abilities somebody else doesn't have
certain features certain things so i can
totally see that taking place okay so i
kind of have an idea who you were in
high school parenting got it books
inspiration got it coming out of high
school if you were to say like my hero
if i were to say coming out of high
school would probably be i don't know an
arnold i wanted to be mr olympia right i
looked up certain people that were you
know uh
people i saw maybe a military leader
somebody like that who was your hero
coming out of high school like in
college
well it'd probably be someone more like
gandhi to be honest you know
so
you know i i looked at gandhi as a
figure of of national liberation for for
india as someone who was
uh very informed by you know spiritual
experience of spiritual views uh but
also took an interest in
uh you know real politics and you know
things like economic development and um
so you know that certainly had a big
impact on me as a young person has that
changed uh to today have your uh has
there been an evolution to your heroes
well yeah yeah
yeah
who would you okay today is is your hero
like a
m m is it a you know i don't know maybe
a
uh president is it a former author is it
a live person is it a dead person
i don't think i relate as quite so much
as i did as a young person to that
concept of having a hero you know
i think we are too individualistic about
you know
the role of individuals in terms of
history you know marxism
is focused more on the collective mass
of humanity right uh
and the the philosophy of dialectics of
over determination yeah is about you
know how we kind of all matter right not
not how
oh it's just about about one great man
in history or whatever you know so i i
mean there's certainly lots of people
that i look to and admire and say these
are people who made great contributions
um and let me just drop probably the
most controversial one just right out of
the gate
and that is joseph stalin
that's probably why i'm on the show uh
because i had some
viral tweets uh
back in the end of june um where you
know i celebrated the legacy of stalin
and and these really sort of took over
and started trending on twitter uh and
that that got me a lot of attention
which has been it's been interesting
i bet you know what's crazy is i have
family members who admire stalin i mean
you got to realize my mother's side
their majority of them are communists
you know interesting their bible was uh
karl marx uh
uh communist manifesto they escaped
their armenians so you figured they were
in russia
you have stalin you have lenin they
admired these men in many different
reasons and then they left
came to iran met my dad my dad was an
imperialist so imagine an
imperialist marrying a communist you
know this thing's not gonna work out
right just a matter of time they got two
divorces in 20 years the second
time they got remarried i was born so
i'm kind of glad they got divorced twice
not once because if it's only one
divorce i don't exist so if you don't
mind i'm going to read the tweet i'm
going to read the tweet and you can
unpack it
so
uh please you're not just going to read
the initial one right you're going to
read that
one so i'm going to go through the whole
thing you tell me
i'll stop
so uh people say i idolize stalin not
true i hold a fair and balanced view the
man was neither a savior nor saint but
he was at once a very successful
revolutionary a great contributor to
marx's theory and said to be a great
listener and collaborator during
discussions and then there are his
successes as a leader first the
foresight to fear a belligerent german
fascism
then the
tactical ability to successfully defeat
the world's greatest invading army
combined with the strength to make
tough decisions that have no easy
answers i simply think one should read
everything the man wrote and then make
up your own mind i would certainly
conclude that he is one of the great
leaders of the 20th
century though so that's what you said
if you don't mind unpacking that
that is the one that uh caused stalin to
trend and and twitter even wrote a
little a little editorial i think
twitter felt that they had to explain
this you know so they said stop you're
trending stalin and then it said dr
asitar bear riverside city college right
yes has
defended style and blah blah and i
thought isn't that interesting somebody
from twitter had to
try to summarize this situation
um
yeah the that tweet got something like
20 million impressions um
and you know
i wrote this knowing that this would
probably be somewhat let's say
triggering right sure um uh you know
we are
taught in the united states uh because
of anti-communist propaganda you know
we're taught that
stalin is just an appalling monster
and there's not a single thing that he
did that was good um
and
this is utter nonsense um
you know the we look at the achievements
of the soviet union and what we find is
that so the soviet union improved the
lives of ordinary people more rapidly
than any any state has ever done in
history
now that's a remarkable achievement uh
so we're talking about
two two things here right first we're
talking about a massive expansion in the
size of the economy right and when i say
that i'm talking about conventional
measurements i'm talking about gdp right
now there are some differences in terms
of how gdp is is reckoned in socialist
countries and so forth let's just leave
that aside right
the fact is that socialism
under stalin
massively grew the economy more than at
any other point in russian history right
so that's one thing now the second thing
gdp doesn't mean that much though
uh in terms of how the average person is
doing right because
the size of the economy can grow and we
have no idea you know where does that
wealth go right does it go to a small
number of people i mean that's typically
the pattern right typically
i mean mark said right the history of
hitherto existing society is a history
of class struggle that means a small
group of people tends to take the lion's
share of the wealth of of an economy you
know when this is going back thousands
of years right um did that happen in the
soviet union the answer is absolutely
not right the wealth went towards
improving the average person's life and
and especially towards improving the
lives of the very poorest that is
extremely unusual right that is in fact
it there there at the time there's no
there's no cases of it there's no
parallel there's absolutely no
historical parallel so
before we get into you know that this
debate is carried out about oh stalin
murdered this and that right stalin did
this you know okay look before we even
get into the details you start with the
big picture you know
when you're approaching something from
far away right you see certain you know
there's the mountain right what does it
look like right
this is the mountain of soviet socialism
right it's a
rapid economic development a
and b
rapid improvement very rapid right
history's rat most rapid improvement in
the lives of the ordinary person
and i think that is a stupendous
accomplishment you know now again i'm
not a fan of the great man theory right
so i'm not saying oh stalin we wear
ships dialing like this right nonsense
that's not true for any leader of any
modern country right i mean you know
what leaders do is supported by millions
of people right um one way or the other
you know um so
but we can say right stalin is is the
leader in in a leadership role right and
and so you know he has certain
responsibility
both positive and negative right
for what happened under that
you know 28 year period or so
of his leadership
and i think it's a huge mistake to look
at soviet history and say oh that was an
economic failure and oh people suffered
and whatever
um
well look you know people suffer in
every single society um could they have
done better maybe right could they have
done better economically maybe but you
start with the actual fact right the
fact is
the economy grew massively under stalin
right the economy industrialized quicker
than any society ever industrialized um
and people's lives got a whole lot
better right and and how do we know that
right we can look at that in terms of
you know the the tools that social
science has to measure that right which
are how long are people living what's
the life expectancy how many babies are
dying before age one right um how many
calories are people taking it right
how many people can read you know these
are the basics right and especially when
you're dealing with a relatively poor
mostly agrarian society a society where
92 percent of the people
work in agriculture
right
these are monumental achievements and
that is why i celebrate that i think
it's
it's a huge mistake and a huge
distortion to allow the anti-communists
most of whom by the way are nazis
to write this history now we can't we
can't allow that right we have to have
the true history you said most you just
made a lot of uh assumptions right there
some would
and you said it in a confident way
which is pretty impressive it's like
going up to a girl at a bar and saying
listen
i'm gonna be the greatest man you're
ever gonna take home and she doesn't
know until she takes you home and then
she says you know what you were like a
four you were okay or you were good and
you delivered so we don't know that but
let me go back and uh measure a few
things that you said you know one but
you know i've had the richard wolf on
before and we had a great time together
i had him on and slavo and jiji has also
been on and a few other socialists have
been on i love talking to socialists
it's a good conversation because i think
the audience wins so
you know you said you know
what it did to the economy it improved
the average person's life
and you know yeah let's not look at the
amount of people that died you know it
is what it is it's you know you have to
do what you have to do and then
leadership there's some negative there's
some positive the part i agree with you
to me a leader is somebody that gets
people to do something they wouldn't do
on their own that could be positive or
negative i think a criminal that says
hey let's go rob the bank i'm like i
don't want to do it i'm telling you we
should go rob the bank
if i end up going and robbing a bank
with a criminal that guy was a leader
who led me to go rob the bank now does
that mean
good leader or a bad leader i define him
as a leader but depends what he's
leading to doing but yeah but to but to
go back and say you know improving the
average person's life here's
one of the challenges i have with that
if you any history book you read it
doesn't matter where you read it stalin
and lenin are not seen as
you know
heroes or mao the only places that you
will read that's positive about them is
typically their own country or somebody
that's maybe favoring them that was from
their lineage that you know says good
things about it but the biggest
challenge with communism for me and i
want to kind of focus on this and we can
go any different angle you want to go i
got different topics we can go to
the the concept of force versus choice
so who is the government to determine
what
improving means to me
maybe i want to build my life at a
different scale
communism doesn't allow me to do that
choice is eliminated under communism
choice is there under capitalism
communism's basic foundation is
force and i know what's good for you now
you're going to disagree with that so i
want to know where you're going to go
with disagreeing that because i don't
think communism exists without a level
of force do you
i would say i would agree with
everything that you said but we have to
change the term communism to capitalism
it is capitalism which gives us no
choices right the average person
has nothing right you cannot have
freedom if you have nothing okay so now
when i say the average person has
nothing what does that mean right it
means how much liquid wealth does that
person have right okay so if we if we
look at
90 percent of americans and you know
richest country in the world right
how much liquid wealth yeah uh do do
people have um
the answer is almost none right almost
none now even if when we start
approaching the top ten percent that
answer does start to change right so the
top percent ten percent has wealth but
when we look at how much wealth they
possess
almost all of it is illiquid right so
almost all of the average person's
wealth is in the form of their home
right
now at the average person does not own a
home they own a portion of a home right
home equity but this is not wealth that
you can use right because the most you
can do with that wealth is you can
borrow against it right you're using it
right now right you're living in it so
if you try and use it you have an
immediate problem which is where do you
live you know um here's the question
right does the wealth that you have even
if you're at the 85th percentile or
whatever right even if you're sort of
near the top of the of the income
distribution under capitalism does it
allow you to stop working and do
whatever you want right imagine if you
could do whatever you thought would make
you the most happy and be of the
greatest benefit to humanity right
does it allow you to do that the answer
is no absolutely not does it allow you
to do that right and i can say this as a
pretty privileged position right i mean
like you know people can look up my
income if they want you know my critics
do this sometimes on twitter you know
and they say look at this communist he's
all privileged and they high income and
whatever right like
like one shouldn't or something as a phd
college professor right um you know the
point is right even if you're doing well
on the income platter
you probably have almost no wealth right
and if you do have some
do you have enough that allows you to
live off the proceeds and do whatever
you want the answer is no except unless
you're in the top 1 right
absolutely not so
if you want to talk about freedom right
that's what i think of as freedom right
i think freedom means you get to control
your time
you get to decide what you do i mean
that's the most precious resource that
we have right i mean let's take that i
don't know i'm taking that so let's go
with that angle right there
so uh
you said everything you said i agree
with except i would replace communism
with capitalism okay so
a couple different things there the
average person you know
wealth is measured based on liquid
savings not based on
uh uh the income they make fine do you
think it's the choice of the individual
on how they spend their money and do you
think there are people that are better
with their money than versus those who
are not good with their money on how
they spend their money some have good
habits some have bad habits right like
when you say
i'm a uh a phd and you're making good
income
you earned the right to do that you went
and got your phd i think you whatever
you're making whether it's 120 150 200 i
haven't looked up your income if you
have the discipline to go i haven't
looked up your income but if you have
the look it up later yeah but if you
have the discipline to go get a phd and
you're a thought leader professor if the
market pays you good money more power to
you but i think that that's more based
on the choice of the individual on how
they spend their money i got guys in my
in in sales
that make a half a million dollars a
year and they're killing it in income
they got a hundred thousand dollars in
savings because they had four lambos for
what you don't need four lambos then i
got guys that make seventy eight
thousand dollars a year and i got two
million dollars in savings so that
argument gets stopped based on the habit
of the individual on what they do with
their money don't you agree
no not at all because you know in order
to in order to have the ability to save
at that level you have to have income at
that level you know like let's not act
like the average person makes 78k or
200k or 500k right that's not those are
not average
incomes right
so you know the the if we want to talk
about who is average we need to talk
about
median figures right so
the median household income in the
united states right and this is
household so that includes
every member of the household right so
there's about a little over two members
of the household on average right in the
united states 160 or so million
households um so the average about
you're about 60k right so that means
half make below that and half above that
right
now income is not the whole story though
right now well i should just say just to
finish that point right we are dealing
with masses of people who don't really
have the option to save because their
their cost of living
is so high relative to their to their
income right and because rents have been
rising much faster
than incomes have right there's
unemployment i mean these are the the
constant problems of capitalism
capitalism
has such an emphasis on employment but
does it guarantee everyone a job
not at all right do you think even under
good times you have millions of people
who are looking for work and can't find
it do you how much of it do things on
the individual to increase their market
value
well individuals can certainly do that
right you can i mean i i'm sort of in
the business of encouraging people to do
that right go to school get your get get
your aaa right get your get your ba get
your bs you know um
but is everybody gonna do that i mean i
think it's it's sort of cruel to tell
everyone uh hey listen we've gotta cross
this river
uh nine of you are gonna make it one of
you is gonna drown good luck you know
what yeah wow that sounds maybe you
could say
look you kind of eat a little too much
and you put on too much weight maybe
discipline yourself a little bit so you
can have stamina a little bit more you
can say
you know what's wrong with us saying
look instead of watching netflix all day
and playing video games maybe spend that
same amount of time learning a new skill
set so the market could increase your
value
is there anything wrong with that is
that cruel
i think it's unrealistic how do you say
that
because we need to look at the fact it's
like it's like musical chairs right
musical chairs the whole point of the
game is there's not enough chairs right
it wouldn't be much of a game if when
the music stopped everybody had a place
to sit down
that's a game
that's a game sure but our economy is
not that different from musical chairs
right i mean like there's always gonna
be millions of people unemployed i mean
we can look at the lowest unemployment
figures in the series right and what
does it translate into it translates
into several million people unemployed i
mean that's just the reality you know
every one percent of unemployment is 1.6
million people or thereabouts right so
you always have millions of people
unemployed in even in the richest
capitalist nations you just hope it's
not you right you just hope that you
hustle hard enough and it's not you
i call that cruel yes absolutely that's
cruel because we are saying look
somebody always has to suffer right
that's a structural cruel do you have
any kids
do you have any kids
i do i have two kids they are 11 and 14.
11 and 14.
do
do you feel
they
have to contribute to society and where
they're living today do they have any
responsibilities or no
yeah everyone has to contribute to
society and i think everybody does you
know you think i think when you say that
you mean in a formal employment capacity
no i just i got four kids i got four
kids and i think about like for example
like what the part i agree with is when
somebody's coming up like listen
you gotta kind of give me an opportunity
to kind of build myself up and then like
you know the culture of middle eastern
culture you know sometimes in america
it's like you turn 18 go figure it out
on your own versus hey listen let me
give you a little bit of a head start
and then go and do your thing you know
so but some may go out and be
independent at 18 and never come back
but some may go at 28 26 25 it varies i
totally understand that part but to
think that an individual
doesn't have to contribute to society
isn't that a miserable life to
not have any way to contribute
positively to the world
i think it is i think it is okay
absolutely i think there's a lot of
dignity and nobility in labor right
and we have been given a wrong picture
of labor by capitalism in fact right we
think of labor as work as toil as
trouble i mean it's this is all through
the economics literature by the way
right this goes back to adam smith right
it's toil and trouble man man lives by
the sweat of his brow right this goes
back to the bible in fact right so
you know these are ideas about labor
that says labor is intrinsically
unpleasant you know
now
i don't think that's true yeah it
doesn't i don't think that's true yeah
yeah no you say it doesn't have to be
right uh
i think there's two different versions
of that okay there's one version of that
which is a kind of capitalist version
that says yeah look work doesn't have to
be shitty but it will be if it's low
wage so don't be stuck in a low wage
shitty kind of job right that's the kind
of capitalist version the marxist
version says
no work is shitty right what makes work
crappy
is the exploitation the alienation the
low wages the precarity the fact that
you never know right is your wage
actually going to even keep up with the
cost of living right those are the
things that make work crappy it's not
the work itself right people say well
who's gonna pick up the garbage this is
a funny one to me because people that
pick up the garbage this is tends to be
a pretty good job actually right like
you know sanitation workers have good
unions they tend to have good wages good
benefits it's a good job right
lots of people would be very happy to
have a good job as a sanitation worker
yeah yeah so you know people always say
this to me under socialism around who's
going to pick up the garbage i don't
know nobody wants to do that right
i don't think that's true right
people want to be of service to society
as long as they are getting their needs
met right okay so there are no
unpleasant kinds of jobs but there are
there are ways of structuring them that
make them crappier or make them better
depending on how they're structured so
absolutely then what you're saying is
what you're saying is
there are some shitty capitalists can't
debate that there are some that are very
uh selfish all they care about is
themselves and they don't treat their
employees right
what do you think of when you when you
think of a capitalist like that i mean
just who springs to mind i mean i'm sure
you're going to say bezos you're
probably going to bring up bezos or
you're going to bring up probably i
don't know who you're going to say who's
the modern day guy you would bring up
musk bezos i don't know who you would
what would you say i don't know i mean
those are those guys
because the way i see it is in the
following way i see it as
if you and i are friends okay let's just
say you and i are friends we have
opposing a lot of friends that we have
political differences i got them here i
mean we we have a podcast with a guy we
don't see either our politics but see
you and i go to dinner together okay all
right we go to dinner i got you don't
worry about it doc this is on me what do
you want you want wine it's on me today
don't worry i got the sushi today great
we go you know i treat you good we have
a good friendship together i respect you
i respect your 14 and your 11 year old
kid i respect your family i see them hey
anything i can get you is there anything
you can do for great and you're
respectful to me we're probably going to
have a long-term relationship together
friendship together and we're going to
enjoy each other's company we have to
agree on everything but we're going to
but if i treat you shitty if i betray
you if i disrespect your kids or your
family
we're probably not going to be friends
for too long because you're not going to
put up with it and i don't think
99.9
of people will put up with it so what
does that mean to me
the market
who is filled with people who make their
money and they become arrogant and
mistreat people
they're the ones that make others who
take care of their employees well
their clients well they make them look
good so you almost need a little bit of
that to get somebody to say you know
what i gotta tell you i used to work at
john's place man he treated me like crap
but man i love working for mary i've
been with her for 11 years every time
i've done well she's given me a raise
i've gotten a bonus she's good to my
family i go on vacation she's giving me
plenty of when i had my two kids i had
my leave time i had this i had that so i
think there is the good end of bad but i
think the bad
makes the look makes a good a win
because you know like a lot of times on
the socialist side or the communist side
the first person they like to target is
bezos and like sanders will go after
them or aoc will go after them look at
this guy he doesn't take care of his
people and he treats them like [ __ ] and
all this other stuff guess what i got a
person here that's my camera girl she
didn't like working at amazon she said i
didn't want to work they didn't treat me
good she left
no one's forced to stay there in
communism you don't have a choice
it's pure force in capitalism if you
work for a shitty boss or a shitty
company you can leave them to go to a
different place you can do that in
capitalism you cannot do that in
communism
yeah but what's your fallback right
let's say you don't have the money to
leave a job you know let's say you don't
have any savings because you're a
low-wage worker right why are you a
low-age worker well you don't have much
skills why well because you come from a
poor family you know education wasn't
available to you
acquiring skills wasn't available to you
now this is true for a substantial
portion now you could say okay hustle
harder you guys
okay fine you know hustling harder is
going to work for a few people
absolutely you know and that's great
capitalism has some social mobility it
is better than the brutal system of
feudalism it's better than the brutal
system of slavery that preceded it
absolutely and marxists are you know
very
willing to admit that you know like like
are we trying to return to the corrupt
monarchies of the past no [ __ ] them [ __ ]
the kings right like are we trying are
we saying slavery was better absolutely
not it's a great thing that humanity has
abolished slavery it's fantastic right
we celebrate that we always have right
um
but are we gonna celebrate a system of
exploitation that requires that needs
and it will always create
a low-wage group which is on the edge of
subsistence and cannot develop
themselves as full human beings because
how can one right when you're
every almost every waking moment goes to
enriching somebody else right
that's the actual reality of capitalism
i mean you know you could celebrate for
me
the relatively small number of
forward-thinking woke capitalists
they're they are they exist they are out
there you know there are good employers
there are you know you know who gets a
lot of press is this guy dan price you
know that's that i had them all by the
way i had them all four months ago
okay well you know they you know you
don't then right yeah add them on go pay
the workers well and they'll do well and
yeah you know this is this is in
enlightened capitalism right
i say it's a illusion you know i say
yeah there's a few of them fantastic
right they make life better than it
would be otherwise but it's still a
brutal system you know like when i say
capitalism doesn't guarantee you a job
that's true right and that's not all it
doesn't guarantee it doesn't guarantee
you a house right so this is why we have
over half a million homeless people in
the united states right
capitalism generates poverty it does not
lift people out of poverty it generates
poverty because it concentrates wealth
in a few hands that is its primary
mechanism i mean are there times where
societies decide to go against that for
whatever reason yeah there are
you but they are at constant risk of
getting undone and this is what we're
seeing right the places that have
nationalized health care let's take
britain for example
their health care system is quite
beleaguered right yeah because they
underfund it why because capitalists
don't want to pay for it right because
it benefits everyone rather than
benefiting a select few capitalism is
all about generating mechanisms that
redistribute wealth toward the rich
and then lying to us and telling us
that's for the average person that's not
for the average person so not at all
here's a question for you here's a
question for you so by the way dan price
do you agree with his philosophy or what
do you think about him
well he's trying to be a good capitalist
employer i think it's better to be a
good capitalist employer than to be a
bad capitalist employer if you ask me
yeah i mean the part when i asked him i
said so at the company he pays everybody
seventy thousand and now it's been a
different story i think he had some
issues with his brother lawsuit family
some things that happened wasn't pretty
uh but uh i asked him i said who owns
the company he said i want 100 i said
that means you own a 100 million dollar
company he says yes and then he changes
position afterwards the guy's worth 100
million dollars his people are working
for him but he owns all the equity so
it's not like he's given the shares of
the company so if you if your position i
applaud you for sticking to your
position of where you are but let me go
back to it so
a question what's more important
living out my purpose and ambitions or
living a safe and guaranteed life what's
more important
i don't know what you can say to that to
an individual right like
you know
should you not be allowed to live out
your purpose of course you should right
but should should somebody starve so
that you can do that right i mean
see this is the disconnect right we need
a system
that truly frees people to
uncover themselves and achieve right to
be who they
can be to develop their potential right
yep
think of the millions of people who are
systematically denied that opportunity
right because of simple stuff right
hunger you know
at any given moment okay there are 850
million hungry people yeah
in the world right now right and nine
million of them will ultimately starve
right each year
that's globally right that's an
incredible figure right um there's
another three and a half million people
that die from lack of access to clean
water so are you gonna tell me that you
can achieve your potential in life when
you don't even have clean water right i
mean what happens when a person doesn't
have clean water they drink dirty water
and then what happens they get an
infection you know i mean they're much
more likely not everyone right thank god
but you're much more likely to die
there's a lot of ways you can die from
drinking dirty water right
another million and a half people die
just because they don't get the most
basic kind of medical care right vaccine
preventable illnesses so
i would say capitalism kills 14 million
people each and every year
that is absolutely due to capitalism all
right so so then let me make the
connection for you if you're interested
i've seen the video i've seen the end
but go ahead audience hasn't seen it go
ahead all right
so what capitalism does again
concentrates resources in a few hands
okay when did this happen we look at the
period from 1870 to 1900 okay this is
when capitalism conquered the world okay
this took the form of now some of it had
already been conquered at this point
right india had already been conquered
china you know is subjugated never fully
colonized
1870-1900 is the scramble for africa
okay this is a period of time where
a lot of the world's land changes hands
okay it goes from indigenous control
to
european control control under a few
hands you end up with african countries
in which 80 percent of the land is owned
by the colonizers right
now people want to tell me that has
nothing to do with starvation today it
has everything to do with starvation
today
what caused that imperialism well it was
caused by the competition among the
capitalist powers for resources for
markets to keep to get access to those
commodities and keep out their
competition right it emerges inexorably
from the logic of capitalism the world
that has been created the world that we
see today
is the product of that right
so that structural cruelty is
inseparable from the system and will
never be undone by capitalism according
to me by the way you know that that part
the only way that kind of cruelty is
possible is with the power of government
you cannot do it without the government
you need to have the government to do
that right so so for me if that did
happen i guarantee you the government
was involved for example monopoly of
course the government you cannot create
a monopoly without the help of a
government it's mathematically
impossible to have a monopoly without
the help of a government to have some
lobbyists come behind closed doors and
help you out but i'm going to go a
different uh direction with you on this
so so i asked the question at the
beginning what's more important pursuing
my purpose ambition or pursuing you know
uh what do you call it just a guaranteed
safe life to make sure everybody else is
happy and everybody else living a safe
life becomes more important than my own
desires that i have let's just say right
now
we got a
22 year old kid that's watching this
conversation you and i are talking let's
call him john okay let's call him jose
he's watching this video and he's
sitting there saying okay
doctor's got a degree he's a phd
patrick had a 1.8 gpa in high school he
doesn't have a degree he doesn't have an
eighth year not an mba not a phd not a
four-year not an associate he just went
in the military came out went into
business and he's done well for himself
in business fine
this kid that's watching this
has the choice
and the capacity
to go be the next bezos and build the
next amazon hypothetically
and he's in there where he has that kind
of drive and intellect to be able to
pull it off right the 22 year old bezos
named jose okay
if he goes and does this in the next 20
years doc
he's going to create 1.3 million jobs
which is roughly what amazon employs
today they got 1.3 million jobs that
means they created a market 1.3 million
jobs
or
he can choose to go out there
and become a major
loyalist to marxist and communistic
philosophies go into school become a
professor
and educate people on why capitalism is
cruel
and it's not the right system
who's
living more of a worthier life the guy
that gives 20 years to build an
incredible company that creates 1.3
million jobs or the guy that goes out
there and says
capitalism sucks and communism is the
way to go who's
who's making their purpose become a
reality
i think if we're dreaming i would like
to see the uh the marxist figure be more
of a revolutionary actually
let's say he's a revolutionary let's say
he's the next styling let's say he's the
next leona let's say he's the next karl
marx do you think the world's a better
place if this kid chooses to become the
next car marx or the next jeff bezos
well we have to distinguish between
these figures these historical figures
right because
marx is a theoretician right if we say
what what are the results that mark's
generated for people's lives the
answer's zero right marshall's never in
a position
marx was never in a position to do any
policy right so now stalin that's a
different story right stalin is actually
the leader of the soviet union right so
and he is in a position to have an
impact on ordinary children's lives and
he did have an impact on ordinary
people's lives right so
these are very different figures
historically right we have to
distinguish between a theoretician right
somebody who generates theory
uh now theory is good right
affects our
understanding of the world right
let's say basil's against stalin
yeah
well which one improved more people's
lives
you gonna ask me this the answer is
unquestionably stalin you really believe
questionably you really believe that oh
absolutely there's no it's not even
close not even close
generating 1.3 million jobs is not the
unambiguous good that you're making it
sound like right the question is what's
the life
the question is what's the nature of
those jobs right
i could create one million internships
for you right now right they're unpaid
right i just create a million jobs boom
paid jobs
oh they they do pay jobs right no
imagine if if if my internships were
also paid they're just paid at a
starvation level of wages
right is that a net improvement these
are not starvation paid jobs though
you know when well
when that's not what the amazon workers
say is it you know well no the people
the people listen the part that you're
right is when the complaints come about
breaks and other people have said that
right but if we have to choose between
the two
you're saying without a debate stalin
would be better for the world than a
bezos
absolutely yeah absolutely and the
historical record is very very clear on
that right
now look
how long were people living in the
soviet union under the czar right the
life expectancy in the soviet union
was about 40 years right yeah so this is
an average figure all right so what it
means is let's take everybody who died
okay and just put in their age okay you
died at six months okay we'll put in 0.5
if you died at 80 we put in 80. okay
diet at 40 put in 40 right
the average of all those numbers okay
that is unbelievable right and that
shows you that this is a pretty brutal
society okay so stalin improved that by
about 30 years right this is almost a
doubling in life expectancy and it's
occurring in a very short period there's
millions of people
millions of people let's not deflect
right let's just let's just say what
happened right what happened was at the
cost massive investment in health care
right at the cost talking about training
thousands and thousands of doctors
building hospitals where they never
existed before right did that save
lives the cost of millions of people
though well let's get to the cost in a
moment right we're just on the positive
side of the ledger right yeah right
did that save lives is the question and
the answer is there is no question that
that's safely
on a grand scale okay so this is a
nation of about 160 million people okay
so when we say that life expectancy on
average increased by about three decades
how many years of human life are we
talking about right we're talking about
hundreds of millions
that is
absolutely astonishing okay
now people say oh maybe the czar could
have done that yeah maybe but the czar
didn't do that right there is in fact no
capitalist nation that has seen that
kind of increase in that span of time no
capitalist nation right so
did people's lives get better yes it's
unequivocal
now
if we want to get into okay stalin
killed millions
that's a detailed argument let's let's
get into it though right
let's get into it because now we're on
the negative side right so we've
established the pro
what's the cost to all this right
i'm listening go ahead yeah
all right so let's let's deal with the
charges okay the biggest charge against
stalin is that stalin
intentionally caused a famine in the
ukraine in 1932 okay
so this is called the holodomor thesis
right
and you know this has been propagated uh
you know since since about the 1930s so
since about the time that it happened
not shortly after right
um
and it was the story was originally
created by hearst right william randolph
hearst hearst sent this guy named thomas
walker okay to the soviet union
to go and observe right
but walker never went to the ukraine
right we know this right because we know
we have his train tickets and stuff
right he never went to the ukraine um
came back and told a story which hearst
was very willing to print right and then
they used pictures that were from the
volga famine they were from the the
bengal famine i mean you know they they
so they used a bunch of misleading
pictures right and tried to cook up this
narrative that said the soviets
intentionally starved ukraine
this argument never had any logic behind
it what the soviets wanted to do was
rapidly industrialize and they knew they
had to increase agricultural
productivity there is
no logical basis for any soviet official
anywhere ever wanting to damage
agricultural productivity their entire
their entire focus was increasing right
so you would have to convince me right
okay that's the logic well maybe
somebody went bad maybe somebody like
show me the order now all right here's
the here's the order okay punish ukraine
okay starve them right well of course
there's no order right in fact what we
find is the opposite right when the
famine began the soviets shipped them
grain
they said drain the grain reserves right
ship them the grain right away oh we
happen to be exporting grains so that we
can get foreign exchange to
industrialize slash that right that's
what they did
there's never been any kind of good
argument that said the soviets
intentionally or let alone stalin
intentionally starved people that is in
fact the truth is the opposite the
soviets ended the problem of famine
which had a long history in russia you
gotta be kidding me let me ask you have
you ever been to russia
i haven't
why not
i would love to go i haven't been able
to travel the world because of you make
pretty good money you can go
you're a good looking guy you look like
you could be russian why haven't you
gone to russia yet oh i didn't realize
that they distributed airline tickets on
the basis of your appearance i should i
should have i should have asked that you
think i'm happy enough to be able to go
to russia phd professor salary you make
pretty good money but i would love to go
you know how it is when you have a
family and you have kids and you have a
house and you know where you yeah if i
love the country as much as you love
russia [ __ ] i'd go live there i don't
know why you don't live there you you so
but but honestly let me ask you this
russia is not currently a socialist
country though you understand that let
me ask you a question though would you
rather live in a capitalistic country or
a communistic country
you know i don't like this question
because i feel like i feel like it
presupposes that the world works like
this you just move wherever in the world
makes you the most happy you know i
don't think that's how the world works
do you i do yes i do for the rich
perhaps not not for the re no no for
those who want freedom and they want to
avoid force [ __ ] i didn't come to
america to be rich my dad was a cashier
at a 99 cent store we lived in germany
at a refugee camp for two years we
escaped iran six weeks after khomeini
died i lived in tehran iran for 10 years
after jimmy carter pushed out the shop
saying the fact that romania was going
to give everybody free housing free food
free rice free phones free tv he came
and he killed
half a million people's lives i mean it
was a treacherous type of an environment
my mother's family escaped armenia and
russia and baku to come to iran because
of what lenin's stalin communism did to
many of these guys they escaped this
this is life like so for you to say
people come only for money no man we
came here because well i can't tell
somebody my mom i was an atheist for 25
years i don't believe in god for 25
years because this stuff i saw it's very
hard to believe in a god if a god it
really exists why the hell would he make
this kind of stuff happen but we
couldn't tell people we were christians
i couldn't tell people that stuff in
iran you know my mother couldn't go out
there and have the kind of career that
men men have here you couldn't do that
women were forced to be able to marry a
man that's 40 years their age at 8 years
old 13 years old that's not cool to do
that so when you say why people leave
it's just for money no
people go to places because that
country's values and principles match
theirs i didn't come to america because
i wanted handouts i mean
come to america to be a billionaire we
came here because i just wanted to be
able to say hey doc what i disagree with
you
cool i disagree with you screw you screw
you cool can we have dinner yeah awesome
i can't do that in iran i can't do that
in the communistic regions i can't do
that in china i gotta zipline china hold
on a minute i'm not celebrating iran
here right and nor am i saying celebrate
you guys that's because of money or
whatever i read iran
i said that the rich have the option to
go wherever in the world they'd like to
go
we weren't rich though we weren't rich
we were very poor
right we were very
and no doubt you guys suffered in the
way that refugees suffer i mean fully
you wouldn't it was not easy to move to
another country i mean i think anybody
knows this right unless you're very rich
in which cases you were not rich no we
were not we have never lived in a house
before listen
yeah i never lived in a house i lived in
a two-bedroom apartment complex when my
mom and dad and my dad were left that
5am kim at 9pm we had a very rough life
i'm not i don't like sympathy i don't
like that kind of stuff because i don't
want you to feel bad for me i'm a very
happy man lucky man all i'm saying to
you is
none of your values and principles that
you admire
are any of those that america stands for
how could you live in a country that
doesn't match any of your values and
principles
i think those are american values and
here's why okay if i go i could i could
talk in front of a giant stadium
full of republicans and you know what
i'd say to them
i'd say how many of you guys have jobs
yes we have jobs right i say how many of
you are proud of the work that you do
right
yes right
how many of you do you think everybody
should have a job everybody who wants to
work
should have a job is there anything more
american
than working hard
and being proud of what you do right
sure i think we'd all be on the same
page well
those are the values in the united
states those are the values of marxism
right
i mean and yet we have this dream in the
united states that if we get rich enough
and if we succeed then we can do what
stop working right
i mean when you win the lottery oh look
and now i'm going to kick back and go in
a hammock and do nothing right
that's kind of our fantasy
how hard was it to get a phd
how hard was it to get a phd it was hard
it was it was perhaps the most difficult
thing that i did in my young life are
you you know what happens when i see a
guy that got a phd
like let me tell you how i do a phd
person i see somebody with a phd i
admire them
i see somebody with a phd and i say this
guy must have freaking put shitload of
hours into reading and studying and
improving probably
have to say no to a lot of parties he'd
probably party a little bit but i think
he had to say no to a lot of them he
probably had that's true no to a lot of
events he probably had a lot of friday
nights and saturdays and sundays while
everybody else was going kicking back he
probably stayed and studied it ain't
easy to get a phd so here's a question
now you and i go to school together i go
to college with you we're bunk let's
just say we're roommates
and i say hey bro what's that
let's go get hammered tonight no dude
i'm gonna study for my this test that's
coming up screw it caroline's come in
mary's coming let's go you get together
with caroline i'm going to get together
with mary you know caroline likes you
dude i'd love to but i got a freaking
who's the wingman here am i the wingman
i think you would i think i'm a
historically good wingman but i think
you would also be a good wingman but all
right the point i'm trying to make to
you is
you busted your ass to get your phd how
about the guy that partied instead of
wanting to bust his ass we need to take
care of him he could have the same hours
to put into it that's when i think
concerned yeah
i can give a very clear answer yes yes
everyone should have a decent life just
by but just by virtue of being alive and
being human right that means everyone
should have food clothing shelters they
can have a job what if i'm an f up
what if i some people are unfortunately
right some people are gonna do drugs all
day what if everyone should have a
decent life that should be our minimal
understanding right just like we have a
very broadly shared understanding right
now right which is that no one should be
enslaved you know i mean ask a thousand
people you get a thousand people who
will agree with that statement should
people be enslaved no they should not
right why not is it because slavery is
not profitable no slavery is incredibly
profitable right for the slave master of
course communists know that communism is
pure slavery i mean that's the the
system is
well now now we're just mixing up terms
of them
under capitalism yeah right even in the
united states just ask everyone do you
think everybody should have a job do you
realize right now i think you're gonna
get pretty strong agreement on that
david is sitting right here is a camera
guy okay yeah and he he runs production
if david right now comes and tells me
screw you patrick you're the worst boss
ever and he leaves you what can i do to
him david i don't want you getting fired
here yeah
what i was conversant to tell you is
what can i honestly do to david what can
i do to you
nothing he gets up and walks out
if in a communistic regime he comes and
puts his finger at the boss and says
screw you where the hell are you going
what's going to happen to this guy poor
guy may go missing we may not find him
by the way let's just say david works
for me
and he goes on but we don't find that
historically though we don't find that
that's not i mean just 40 million people
got killed it's not that many people
it's just not you know it's it's just
it's just yeah but that's not a true
number though it's 560 million you're
right it's more like 60 million it's a
bigger number no no neither of those
numbers are right
you know what i appreciate about you is
the following here's what i appreciate
about you is
you
have
your own thoughts on believing the data
that a stalin's regime would give you
to say that's the date on how things got
better for somebody that is an intellect
like you who's read way more books than
i have and knows history probably a lot
more than i do that's the world you're
in that's the sport you're playing right
that's why i'm interviewing you and i
have you want to get your perspective on
it sure you know but let me ask you this
does not every government have similar
motivations to lie about the numbers i
mean doesn't the united states have
similar motivation i don't just make
yourself look good i don't think i lag
about the numbers the only difference we
have here here's the only difference
here remember who charged this trump did
tr when trump was running he made a lot
of hay out of this he said the official
unemployment rate is nonsense the
unemployment rate is actually way higher
i remember that but guess what you know
what we have here's what we have you
just validated my point i was about to
make to you here's the point i'm going
to make to you
is okay ma
china jeeping right
they say
yeah kobe came and it left and we're
freaking partying our asses up well it's
a big deal we're good the economy's
grown we're blowing up people are so
happy to be in china they just love it
here it's a fantastic world but i tell
you facebook twitter youtube you're not
welcome in china and if somebody posts a
video on any of those platforms let me
tell you we're coming after you why jack
ma gets up there and gives a speech an
anti-government speech by this much he
goes missing for 90 days how the hell
does a guy worth 60 billion dollars that
created a bunch of jobs disappear
their elon musk disappeared their bezos
disappeared just because they made a
comment against the government moral the
story is the following
you can get up today and talk [ __ ] about
biden you got a job at fox news and cnn
you can get up there and talk [ __ ] about
trump you definitely have a job at msnbc
try getting up there and talk [ __ ] about
jeep in china you have a job at the
cemetery and it's six feet under you
cannot talk [ __ ] over there or in russia
you don't have that that's not true at
all though that's not true fantastic so
so so why don't they believe in freedom
of speech
why why don't we have facebook youtube
twitter over there why can't we see
what's going on why don't they go
facebook live so we can see what's going
on in china
well you have to understand the history
of china right china is a
long-established civilization
that was
very severely humiliated and basically
colonized right not exactly but
basically right like the britain had its
way with china it did not deign to
conquer the entire territory but it
shaved off the part that it wanted right
hong kong you know the the port part
right um uh and it got the policies that
it wanted that came out of the opium
wars um it subjugated china right so
and you know this caused i mean you know
this is part of a whole string of
different defeats and humiliations in
the early 20th century right that led to
uh you know the downfall of the qing
dynasty and the warlord period and
chinese nationalism and ultimately
communism right um
this is china just saying to the
capitalist powers of the world it's just
saying no right you are not going to run
our country we are going to run our
country now that's a very important
moment right now does the does the
capitalist world say oh fine okay thanks
have a great day right
no they do not right they say we are
gonna bring you the [ __ ] down by any
means necessary okay we're gonna bring
you down through infiltration we will
bring you down through planting people
inside your government we will bring you
down through outside media we will
create an entire organization called
radio free asia right just designed to
spread lies and propaganda right so
does china ban a few as many of these
things as they can yeah and should they
absolutely they should right would the
united states do that would the united
states ban things like that if there was
a massive
hugely funded chinese effort to spread
propaganda in the united states
the u.s ban it no tick tock and zoom
what i mean what else you want to say
tick tock zoom go to the sites we have i
can go to china's youtube website they
can't go on
do you think that i don't know how
familiar you are with radio free asia
radio free asia is a completely
propaganda outfit it is funded by the
state department okay
do you think that tick tock is
equivalent to radio free asia as a
propaganda mechanism or or do you not
know enough about these things to say or
do you have a sense
i have a sense of the fact that in china
you don't have freedom of speech like we
got in america
in america if you disagree with trump
you can go out there and talk about it
you cannot do that in china you cannot
do that in the ussr that you love you
can't do that and under stalin do you
say one no
no there's plenty of criticism of xi
jinping there's plenty of criticism of
you
you think during a stalin era i can say
things about stalin get away with it
come on we can't be that naive
you cannot you cannot organize to bring
down the state not only you have
what if i just start to behind closed
doors campaign and i say hey i want to
run as an opposition against you and i
want to run as a democrat you can't do
that
their red line is look you can run you
can run against anybody as long as it's
in the communist party right why is that
well because there's a long history of
capitalist powers funding oppositional
candidates right trying to bring down
the system again
through a million different means if you
study the history of u.s imperialism and
u.s intervention you will find an
unbelievably long list of dirty tricks
right
these dirty tricks have been used
everywhere to bring down governments
that are democratically elected right i
will i'm never i'm never gonna defend
a uh uh talk you know like the taliban
against the afghanistan war okay
listen if you go out there and get
involved in everyone's business
and then you all of a sudden want to
step away i'm sorry america but you're
gonna create a lot of enemies and
america's create a lot of enemies war
involvement a lot of different business
you and i are probably gonna agree on
that part because some of this stuff
when i was in iran and they hated us and
they would scream matic battle ombre
call like death upon america
yeah right they don't like the
westernized philosophy but what i'm
saying to you is all of those tactics
fair yes
but dude in america you and i can get up
and talk
in america you can be a professor
at riverside you know city college
and you're a full-on communist you are a
full-blown communist and yeah but do you
know how many people are surprised by
that i mean
take a guess at how many have called for
my job publicly
out of those stalin remarks right
you know like how how powerful a person
do you think it would take i don't think
you get me fired i don't think you would
get fired
well you know thank you and i sincerely
hope that you're right you know in fact
i'm staking my livelihood on that no i
don't think you would get fired here's
why would you wouldn't do you think a
congress person could get me fired
do you think a senator who might get it
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question
dude come here you know i used to work
at a different university the university
of southern maine and their president
fired a hundred out of 400 tenured
faculty members some of them right near
retirement
can that happen absolutely if of course
i mean listen if the president of united
states is silenced by twitter you could
get fired so you know if the president
could get fired you can definitely get
fired but you know the left has a
monopoly and education you know they
1341 professors lean to the left and to
the right so
there's a monopoly in the world you're
in all i'm saying from my end is think
about it this way why do i have you on
this is a pro entrepreneurship pro
capitalism youtube channel why do i have
you on
like other channels wouldn't have you on
why do i have you on do you know these
are my favorite conversations
i think you like good conversations with
people who are gonna push back a little
bit because that's what creates a fire
in terms of the discourse right but you
know what it is also for me is
as long as you're respectful no the for
me you know who wins in this
conversation who do you think won today
the viewers that's right
that's what that's what i want to do the
audience is going to go walk away and
say listen i i agree with what he said
in this side and i agree with you pat
what you said on the following side so
look i i i've really enjoyed this i can
go a couple different things here but
i'll give you any any final
positions you want to take yourself i
mean one of the things i wouldn't mind
reading because we haven't yet we can
wrap up with this a little bit of china
we got 14 more minutes and it will wrap
up
is
mao okay you said a couple things about
mao okay i'd like to get your take on
mao
so you said uh uh you tweeted support
for chinese dictator mao uh describing
him as one of the greatest revolutionary
leaders of all time why don't you unpack
it because you have good things to say
about him you call this him uh the
greatest revolutionary leaders of all
time that meaning ahead of uh stalin
tell me why him
well yeah mao is an incredibly important
figure uh you know in terms of china but
also in terms of the history of marxism
and communism
you know i mean we what we have here if
we look at the long historical frame
right we look at the last 150 years okay
so since you know the
development of kind of modern marxism
the communist manifesto etc right this
is a about is 170 years old or so okay
now in the at the time there's no
socialist countries at all right we look
at 1848 europe is emerging out of
feudalism and as making a kind of the
final transition away from the feudal
aristocracy and toward you know liberal
bourgeois kind of democracies and so
forth right
so
socialism at the time is highly
theoretical you know um and you know
that's why you have this relatively long
document right the the communist
manifesto and it has to say like here's
what we mean by it because the term is
being used by lots and lots of people
right um here's what we mean by it okay
but when we get to by the time we get to
like 1949 the time of the
chinese revolution we're in a very
different situation right now we've had
successful socialist revolutions
so mal can study these right that the
the chinese communist party
can study this and say what do we think
has worked and what hasn't worked right
now they are a little bit off the map in
terms of
you know marx had predicted that the
contradictions of capitalism would cause
workers to get together and say hey we
have some similar interests here right i
mean we're all working for a wage and
our employers would like to pay us less
they'd like us to work harder they'd
like to work longer so they can have
more profits our interest is
overturning this system right our
interest is look the wealth that we
produce should go to us that's you know
that that's the prediction and so
marx's thought that the revolution would
occur in the most developed capitalist
countries now what a surprise it was to
find that wasn't true right they
occurred in the least developed like the
the least
russia is the least developed uh
capitalist country
capitalist feudal country uh in europe
china has a very little capitalism in
1949 right it has a little bit in the
cities but is again mostly an agrarian
country so mao works with this right mao
works with the peasantry
lives with the peasants for 20 years
right during a long march
and wins them over i mean
that is remarkable right to see a leader
that emerges from
constant contact with the poorest people
in the society right
now these are people who are exhausted
by warfare right because they had the
war they had the warlord period you know
they had internal fighting for decades
and decades and decades and so their
peasants are familiar at the time with
what do armies do when they come through
here's what they do
they steal your food
they rape your daughter
and they do whatever the hell they want
right i mean like do they make your
lives better in any way right
no they don't you know the only thing
that you can say that they do positively
is they're fighting against another
power that's trying to
take you over right so and this is the
time when when mao and the communists
really start to become popular right
they're fighting this war against this
you know the the woman tang right um
uh it's when the japanese invade china
right
that the differences between these two
different armies right so we have the we
have the kmt and we have the red army um
but mao is insists on a different kind
of conduct for his soldiers right he
says
you have to pay for what you take right
we have to treat people you know much
differently than any army has ever
treated people because these are the
people that we need to convince right we
can't just take their stuff and you know
like
we we have to be different than that
and he does this right he gains massive
widespread the red army goes from having
something like 40 000 troops
having a 4 million right and that shows
its unbelievable popularity right
because so not only does he treat people
ethically right and he's in a position
of power i mean even if you have if you
have 40 000 an army of forty thousand
that's small relative to the kmt but
that's still a lot more power than any
peasant has right so you can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want in that situation
right but did mao no right mao treated
people very very fairly because he saw
it as like these are the people that
we're actually fighting for you know
um now does every leader do that no not
at all right most most guerilla fighters
are incredibly unethical you know like
they mostly do whatever the hell they
want right now then we could say what
did mao do when he was in power right
what mao did when he was in power is a
very similar to stalin right he said we
need to get the entire country organized
the state is going to be the major
employer but we're going to do something
that's never been done in china which is
we're going to make sure that everyone
has the basics okay in china this is
called the iron rice bowl right it's a
bundle of guaranteed consumption goods
okay that never ever existed any time in
chinese history right so
the fair and you know this is among the
first things that are done right even
while the economy is still emerging from
the wreckage
of you know tens of millions of people
died in the fighting in the invasion of
the japanese and so on right
mao immediately turns toward improving
the lives of the very poorest right
these are things that i certainly admire
and i think anybody should admire right
i mean like if you care about the fate
of the poor the fate of those who are
the least advantaged in a society
well this is a leader who put their
needs very much
you know near the top right now i'm not
going to say at the absolute top right
because every leader has the same
challenge which is how do you keep power
in a world of hostile nations
they do do they want to eat your lunch
do they want to depose you absolutely
they do
do they have more power than you yeah
they do right
we can see this you know the united
states supported the kmt
for decades after they fled to taiwan
they said well that's the legitimate
government of china right so
you know we're not dealing with an equal
kind of playing field here where the
capitalist powers say oh yes well
whoever ends up running the country is
fine no not at all right we are dealing
with
a war right that war is the working
class versus the bourgeoisie
so you know what's interesting i'm
sitting there thinking i'm like this
guy's never written a book one you
should write a book because communists
would love to
uh uh i hear that from people actually
but thank you for saying that right now
you you sound so devout to them like
you're such a true believer at least
when i spoke to slavoji he had some
doubts
and he was questioning certain areas of
communism that maybe didn't produce the
results that he's more skeptical today
than he was before i talked to richard
wolff he's more socialist he's not a
full-blown communist at your level
he's a little bit different than you
although some similarities you know
i just pulled up something right now i
typed the the most evil dictators of all
time okay number one is mao 49 to 78
million deaths number two is stalin 23
million that's that's what the site says
now give or take you know is what it is
i'm curious just just purely out of
curiosity what do you think about hitler
well hitler is a fascist monster you
know uh somebody who committed genocide
somebody who is uh a would-be
imperialist yeah hitler did not focus
his imperialism on africa as the other
capitalist powers did in the late 1800s
he focused his imperialism on
russia right i mean the drive was to go
east to give the german people living
room laban's realm right i mean that was
the that was the german phrase
now they did that under the
understanding that the slavs and the
russian people were sub-human you know
now they had a little bit of a problem
ideologically because you know they had
a white supremacist ideology
and they did recognize that the slavs
and the russians were or
at least some of them were white right
but they used this very old kind of
mythological idea that said that the
slobs had black bones and i mean it was
this just utter [ __ ] right so what
you have here is you have
fascist nationalism which seeks to
conquer territory based on racist
ideology right now i think that that's
pretty well established by history right
the result of that is that tens of
millions of people die okay
that's unequivocal um
now people like to draw equivalencies
between anti-communists do between
hitler and stalin
there are no equivalencies
none of the things that i mentioned
apply in the slightest to
the soviet union to any socialist
country they don't apply to china
saying hitler stalin and mao
and then saying something after that
just advertises your ignorance right
there's there is no
there's no point in saying you know
anything further at this point you
correct me
you cracked me up
now in terms of zijac i you know
doubt makes a good philosopher you know
and and zizek is a great philosopher so
you know is it appropriate yes right and
richard wolff you know look he's my
mentor i love him you know um we have
some maybe differences of opinion but i
think we just have a different style is
more like it you know i think the
differences of opinion are minor
actually but we have you know we have
different areas of emphasis let's say
right um you know i have a i have a
style that's a lot more unequivocal
right because i'm acting as more of a
kind of
ideological warrior you know than i am
as a kind of sure academic and oh let me
weigh each side
right i do that in my written work but
you know i'm here as a popular figure
not as uh
for what it's worth for what it's worth
i thought you were going to be a lot
more antagonistic than you were i have
to tell you that i i thought you were
you were gonna be a lot more
uh uh coming from a place of
this thing was gonna get zero to pissed
off i did an interview with what's his
name
uh what is his name lucian truscott i
don't know if you've ever seen it or not
if you're not if you want to entertain
yourself he's a great great great great
grandson of thomas jefferson who wanted
the statue to be removed if you want to
be entertained just watch the first
minute you'll crack up it's a 27-minute
interview i'm gonna do a quick speed run
with you i'll give you a name tell me
one word that comes to mind and i will
wrap it up
anyway that comes to mind or you can say
skip
uh with any name so
churchill
uh
what's the word that comes to mind with
churchill i mean
um
you know i think of churchill with the
the bengal famine really you know um and
if we want to look at a leader who
intentionally starved people i think
that's that's who we're looking for
we're not looking at stalin or mao we're
looking at churchill
bernie sanders
bernie sanders i like bernie um you know
he seems like a figure of of um
of integrity um
although i think he's burning a lot of
clout right now because uh you know
embracing the biden administration
uh and and going towards incrementalism
um you know started off saying medicare
for all and now is saying lower the
eligibility age
you know
this is the kind of thing where what i
had always said about bernie is bernie
is the furthest right that i'm willing
to go you know
wow okay
i consider him to be a right-wing
leftist um because he's not saying oh
you know let's expropriate the rich he's
not saying that right he's not saying
let's end capitalism he's saying oh and
tinker with it and make it work better i
don't believe in that would you say the
furthest right-wing or the furthest
socialist
you know what i mean like further
socialist right-wing
bernie is a social democrat right he's
somebody who favors a reformed
capitalism that has higher wages and
more benefits or whatever right
that
you know i consider that to be a good
result but i think the only way you're
going to get to that is
through socialism basically you know
like i i and that that's what we've seen
historically as well about aoc
aoc i think you know
it's a figure that a lot of us had high
hopes for and you know it's exciting and
whatever to see a socialist but this is
somebody who is
um first of all became way more famous
than their than their power
uh you know sort of
uh merited right like
aoc is a freshman congress person
basically no power you know um your
powers as a congressperson depends on
what coalitions can you build what
committees are you on and so forth right
aoc had basically none of that but she
became it was just catapulted to fame
because she's
young and oh a socialist and whatever
you know fox news really made her famous
um and then becomes oh this is the lion
of the left um
but you know leftists look at her and be
like what has she actually done you know
um what policies has she done that
actually improve people's lives and the
record there is non-existent so you know
i i like aoc you know she seems like a
good person whatever but you know
it's like uh you throw a handful of sand
at an oncoming tidal wave you're not
really gonna change the result there you
know elizabeth warren
elizabeth warren i put in a very
different position elizabeth warren is a
very opportunistic uh politician in my
view somebody who you know bernie's out
there campaigning in 2016 talking about
medical medicare for all
talking about the 15 minimum wage
uh talking about everyone should have a
job what's elizabeth warren doing
deafening silence right um then endorses
clinton
then comes and adopts that program
without a word like what the hell is
that in the 2020 campaign i mean and and
the entire democratic field adopts all
of bernie's proposals
why don't if you if you guys support the
proposals then you should be supporting
bernie right but none of these people
did that i just think it's opportunistic
yeah and you know it's
a lot of my colleagues in academia you
know love elizabeth warren and so maybe
i will end some friendships by by
speaking
but
at this point i think probably nobody
cares um
you know i just think it's
it tells you whether you really support
a program though you know like do you
support it rain or shine you know or
just shine you know i don't think she's
a true believer i think like you said
she's an opportunistic that makes sense
how about fidel castro
well fidel castro's interesting one
because fidel castro started off as a
revolutionary as a nationalist
revolutionary not as a socialist
interestingly enough right so fidel
embraces socialism
later right uh he's just sort of it's on
the fence for a little while right it's
kind of the us's response that pushes
fidel to to socialism but once he does
that he very much embraces it right so
you know one of the first things that i
just wrote about this for a new
publication called the international
people are interested you can google
that um i wrote about the economic
achievements of of cuba uh one of the
first things that they do they they uh
expropriate the land right so like i
mentioned in cuba similar to lots of
places in africa and so forth you had
most of the land being owned by a very
small land owning class
and you know
the castro and the revolution they said
look we're not gonna do that anymore
we're gonna we're gonna turn the land
over to the peasants it then became
state property the state the state
section uh went to about eighty percent
of the land
they also had individual peasants also
owning uh their land individually so
they had a kind of mixed system um but
you know in general i think i am i'm
very favorably uh inclined towards
castro and the revolution there also
generated very good results i got two
other names for you noam chomsky
noam chomsky um
yeah big figure on the left not someone
i've ever really been a fan of just
because i don't see him as having a very
good answer to like the question of what
should be done you know
noam chomsky is someone who has good
critiques you know like he critiques
his critiques of the media are very
solid right critiques of imperialism
good right he knows a lot about you at
the history of u.s imperialism and
that's that's very good uh but does he
have a very good vision of what should
be done you know you said hey noam
chomsky you can write your ticket what
would it look like i don't think so you
know he doesn't have he doesn't system
that so that only takes you so far as a
critic you need to have a positive
vision of your own
um
and last but not least
our our current president your president
my president joe
biden well joe biden is just the next
iteration of of reagan you know i mean
like we've we've had a reagan government
since reagan i mean that's that's what
we've had you know clinton
the masterpiece of clinton is that he
rebranded the democrats you know he said
we're eisenhower republicans now i mean
this is literally what he said right so
you know clinton
and and the democrats since clinton have
been very much in that vein
the republicans have gone in a very
different direction right the
republicans have gone uh toward a kind
of
you know nationalist and fascist kind of
direction um the democrats are the ones
now saying we are the technocrats and we
are the ones that will you know
tinker with the capitalism and make it
work better and whatever
i personally don't believe in that i
think that's the that's the kind of
keynesian vision again right um but they
also do this with a very aggressive
militarism you know the the us military
machine costs about 1.25 trillion
dollars a year once you add everything
up that's a stunning amount of wealth to
spend on killing people
i got to tell you i enjoyed having you
on uh appreciate you for answering
questions and working uh
and going back and forth this was a
blast like i said earlier i enjoy doing
these things
uh we're gonna put the link to both your
youtube channel there's a video i think
there's ten criticism you give up
capitalism some i think i don't know
what the title is we'll put the link to
youtube channel below if somebody wants
to watch it we're going to put the link
to your twitter as well below if anybody
wants to go send a tweet at him and i i
would love to hear what she took away
from today's interview having said that
doc appreciate your time it's been good
having you on
thank you so much and you know i'd love
to come back so if you want to have me
back on the show
let's have dinner sometime i am paying
no you're not
i will take you up on that off and i
definitely look forward to it appreciate
you we'll definitely have you back on
all right thanks for watching take care
bye-bye so when's the last time you saw
a communist and a capitalist sit down
together have a good conversation at the
end one of them says hey i'd love to
take you out to dinner especially the
communists we made history today anyways
it was a great conversation
curious what you took away about what he
had to say he made a lot of
strange comments again if you're
watching this uh doc a lot of strange
comments were made would you take away
from it comment below if you enjoyed it
put a thumbs up if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so i
got two other videos i want you to watch
one of them is with me and richard wolff
if you've never watched it he's the
number one socialist professor in
america according to forbes click over
you to watch it and the other one is an
interview i told
you know a satara about is lucian
truscott well within a minute he got
pretty upset if you haven't seen this
one you want to be entertained
go watch my interview here take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you